publica it says it's the billionaire
playbook how sports owners use their
teams to avoid millions in taxes here it
is when i heard this i was shocked by
the way i couldn't believe this here it
is little little
behind the curtain right
so amortization allows teams allow
sports teams owners to take nearly all
of the team purchase price as a tax
deduction here's how it works by the way
we talked about amortization
it's which is the gradual reduction of
debt over a period of time let's say for
example you purchase a sports team for 2
billion just 2 billion steve ballmer i
believe
um bought the la clippers steve ballmer
was
um microsoft guy right microsoft bill
gates he was the intrapreneur
uh he became ceo after bill gates
and uh he bought the clippers and he's
the guy going crazy on the sidelines but
they just seem can't seem to win um so
basically let's say you buy a team for 2
billion um typically about ninety
percent of that purchase price or one
point eight billion if you're doing math
is
amortizable and amortizable ammort is
about
an amortizable amortizable i'm more it's
a tough word i swear to god i mean even
financial experts over here have tough
am amortization
amortizable let's call it um the tax
deductible deductible let's call it mort
more more you can mortgage
more more that which means it's treated
like an asset that loses value over time
do you hear that it's an asset that
loses value over time much like some
real estate sometimes okay
that can be expensed aka
write-offs that means under the tax code
over the next 15 years you can claim a
120 million dollar expense for your
sports team
for your for your sports team each year
let's say your sports team makes 50
million per year
and you have other sources of income
that add that add 150 million on top of
that normally you'd pay almost 40
percent of your income in taxes we
understand that there'll be in the top
tax bracket 40 there it is however with
amortization you can remove 120 million
from your income which means you don't
have to pay taxes on it then you only
pay taxes on the rest you save about 45
million in taxes each year or 650
million over 50 over 15 years in some
cases owners can write off even more
than 90 of the purchase price if you
enjoyed that short clip from the size
cast click here to watch another click
here to watch the full episode or just
stay broken
[Music]